congratulations drew why did you guys
get flagged for excessive celebration in
a moment when the NFL was going to be
celebrating the celebration listen I
didn't even realize we got fired but I'm
variation wanted it yeah we were
watching and I go wait they just flagged
them for a celebration
and then the NFL was gonna stop the game
and have this celebration it felt like
it kind of hits you right then I don't
know if if it was in that moment but it
kind of hey you're gonna pass the old
time record here then you do it what
were you thinking right after that I
mean just just a flood of emotion you
know my mind this entire week was just
on obviously trying to stay as focused
as possible and just weren't in the game
you know and going out there and saying
very locked in one play at a time stay
in the moment and just the hard part was
that one was you know he 201 yards you
know so you know maybe it happened
sometime in the third quarter or maybe
even early fourth quarter something like
that you know expecting it to be a tight
game you know the way that we played the
Redskins last year it was that dramatic
game came back in the end but it was
tight in the whole way and so you know I
I just didn't want to kill the momentum
I'm just so focused on the game and
winning the game and so I think the fact
that it happened when it did you know to
me to drive at the end of the second
quarter where you know it's on a long
touchdown to hospital I don't think the
script or any better do the kids do your
boys get the day off yes they do get the
day off actually I don't know if we told
the teachers about and you had a
teaching moment there you set the record
and you're got a teaching moment with
your boys on the sideline you know I
always try to give indeed some moments
we have a lot of fun together you know
they they love sports and and I feel
like Sports is the greatest teacher when
it comes to just life skills and so
there's things I kind of whisper in
their ear every night before they go to
bed and
that was one of those things but just a
very special moment for them to be a
part of if I would have told you in 2006
hey you know what you're gonna be the
all-time passing leader in NFL history
at some point what would you have
thought well I mean I would have thought
you're crazy you know that was back to
the time when I wasn't wasn't sure if I
was going to be able to come back and
play football if I did didn't know how
effective over be you know I've always
been an extremely confident guy but um
you know I still that just you know some
of these some of these numbers were just
so far out there you know I'm I don't
know if I told you this but my my first
precede my first game ever in the league
preseason 2001 was at Miami so at the
Dolphins I'm walking to the stadium
looking up to the Ring of Honor and
seeing Dan Marino's name in the Ring of
Honor with all of his statistics and I
remember just sitting there in awe of
those numbers just saying how in the
world you play that long and that well
to accomplish those things and it was my
very first preseason game and at that
time I was just hoping to make it become
a starter in the NFL someday and it's
just it's been an unbelievable journey
thus far here we are 18 years later and
I had the chance to play for some
unbelievable coaches and with some
unbelievable teammates at all that
played a huge role in this and so you
know that was my thing is I just hope
all those people know just how how
important they've been in my life and
what it in so said babe Marino was
tweeting who you congratulating you
during the game like how surreal is that
that all of a sudden this guy that
you're thinking those numbers are
impossible he's tweeting to you
congratulations during the game last
night
just yes pretty incredible this so
grateful and you know especially guys
like Marino and farmers and Manning and
these guys who paved the way for all of
us I mean so many others as well but
obviously those are the guys that were
holding a lot of these records I mean
those those are the guys that that I
looked up to as a kid that many of us
looked up to as a kid that are playing
the league right
and so to have those guys not reaching
out is pretty special
these drew brees the record-setting
quarterback with the New Orleans Saints
joining a stampatto show now that you
set the record can you now come clean
that your 511 and not 6 feet tall all
right it's a whole lot cooler if you're
511 drew just saying no I'm still I'm
still a proud member of what was the
celebration like when you got home
oh man well we bring out with the kids
for a bit and then I had a bunch of my
friends my college roommates my best
friends in town and my my family my dad
and just some other mentors people that
have been with me through this whole
journey and just wanting to spend time
with them and so we we hung out for a
bit just reminisce a little bit so it
was it was great to have that moment if
I walk into your house do I know what
you do for a living
probably not your you it's just think
I'm like a struggling father all the
kids all the kids later having dogs run
it up and just craziness you know it's
um we got it we got a pretty crazy
household through the day well do you
have to hide all your awards because the
kids you know may take it to Show and
Tell or who knows what your boys would
do with that stuff yeah I've got that
most of stuff is stowed away I have some
in my office but for the most part like
we just we make the house about the kids
and just trying to create the best
environment we can for them it's like I
said it's it's it's pretty wild at our
house there's no slowing down I know we
keep it Brady talks about it or we keep
talking about it with Brady about when
does he how long's
play and he says 45 I feel like you're
playing longer than Brady is you and
your wife talk about a time frame here
as long as you want
not I don't know I'm just I'm really
gonna take it one year at a time and
just enjoy enjoy every second of it
because I know when it's over it's over
but man you know I'm having fun right
now did you get a who dat did was
somebody just saying something to you
that was a jogger I'm outside most
everybody do they do they people just
drive by and walk up to the door and say
hello to you yeah I I took a picture
with a family from Hawaii when I got
home Sunday from some from the office
you know spend two hours with the family
before heading over the whole team hotel
Santa Claus all the way from Hawaii to
watch watch the game tomorrow night
so how cool is that President Obama
tweeted to you as well like I'm gonna
guess your you were pretty full of
tweets and phone calls the whole week
responding to people via text hey thank
you for making time for us we've always
enjoyed the relationship and it's a
proud moment there's great moment to
watch last night and good luck the rest
of the season thank you it's a drew
brief Saints quarterback you know he he
said to his PR people that he wanted to
do this show we asked a week ago and he
said that if he was setting the record
then he was going to join us today so
we've had him on I had him on when he
was in college his senior year at Purdue
I'm old
now you start to see guys entire careers
play out and you go and when people talk
about you know what separates good from
great and great from hall-of-famers the
fact that drew brees two years ago came
on our show and this was during the
Superbowl and we handed him his draft
profile what was actually being said and
most the the things that were said were
negative and he was just now he's
already a Hall of Famer so this is only
a couple years ago and he's reading this
and he's reading all this and you can
just see where he is just going hitting
me they said this about are you is this
true so he gets ready to leave our
studio at the Super Bowl and you know I
say goodbye doing me and he goes oh hold
on he walks back over to paulie's desk
picks up the piece of paper and he goes
can I keep this and Paulie goes yeah and
he folds it up neatly puts it in in his
back pocket and then we asked him about
it I think last year like do you still
have that goes oh yeah put it my locker
his motivation and it's so everything
he's accomplished in and to have a chip
on your shoulder I mean that's he's
never gonna be satisfied and the Great's
are never satisfied for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]